okay you ready for me to turn over yeah
right
okay now this one it looks a bit icky up
because you've got negative numbers
there okay but we can still work this
out right so what we want is well let's
take one a time if I'm working at this
distance the rise
okay the rise now again rises to do with
is it the X or the Y it's a lie it's
with the Y very good okay so here's one
of the Y coordinates and here's the
other one
three and negative one okay now I can
think about this a couple of ways okay
now here what's this distance well
here's one way of approaching it okay
how far this distance from the x axis up
to be look carefully
isn't the X or Mike wonder it's the like
women right it's the Y so now that dis
is there is three okay that's right
now if you go the other way going
downwards right I have to go down to
negative one right so so this distance
is one so you can add these two together
you can see the distance is four right
does that make sense the distance from
here to here will be plus one be careful
the rise is from here all the way from
down the bottom here right all the way
up to the top oh yeah okay now you have
a look does is this side is this whole
side can it be - that would be it it's
shorter than this part I can't be right
it's got to be four before so yeah let
me let me show you another way okay
remember I'm trying to work out this
whole distance here okay now come back
to the previous side how do we work it
out last time right I took away one
right so I won from six six take away
one six minus one okay
in other words I did this y coordinate
minus this y coordinate you see that six
minus one
so now when I come to this situation I'm
gonna do exactly the same thing but
watch out for the negatives watch what
happens I'm going to do this
y-coordinate three take away now what's
the other y-coordinate it's negative one
exactly right now when you take away a
negative what you get positive right
that's three plus one that's four right
so you got two ways to think about it
you can think oh look there's a 3-part
there's a one-pot right now you're up
and down so what you got here hiding in
here
right there's actually a one there so
this is this part here this part that is
minus one times one so they're
reasonable duplication but it's kind of
hidden in there it's tucked away okay so
it let me write it again it's three
minus a negative one okay and that's a
four okay so there you go there's my
there's the rice right and I'm gonna
work out the run in exactly the same way
except this time it's the x coordinates
which is five and negative four okay so
I'm gonna go in five take away negative
four right and there's a double negative
so it's five plus four which is 9 okay
good well done so now I've got my
lengths I've got the two shorter sides
of the right angle triangle so I can go
back to Pythagoras now I can say a B
squared is equal to the squares of the
two short sides right and the reason is
both a giris
now I'm going to get to that in a second
good question most short answer is no
and I'll show you what I take the square
root and yeah it's what I'm gonna get
under here this is 16 plus 81 68 plus 81
which i think is the square root of 97
but um but just like the previous
question 97 is not a square number okay
so I can leave it like that I could say
look that's exact or alternatively I can
approximate it what was it again my
point okay so I'll just that's a good
question I'll refer back to you before
right do I am I supposed to approximate
or not and the question is well look at
look at what the question asks you
sometimes they'll ask you to approximate
give it to me two decimal places give it
to me one decimal place if they say
nothing then leave it you leave it like
that